you guys want kids yeah
uh i might as long as they don't cry
tell them [ __ ] to shut up
they don't i'll leave them in the
[ __ ] pickup truck while i'm at the
strip club
[Laughter]
having a beer it's funny because i i
have i'm working on this project right
as that project and the person taking
care of the project has a baby and she
always has a baby with you
with her i mean and it's funny because
i see how i'm not gonna google the
[ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up i don't do that [ __ ]
i don't do that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you little [ __ ]
i was talking
i was talking to that kid like that and
she was like yo that's my kid mitch calm
down he's four months old he doesn't
give a [ __ ] what's good little [ __ ] and
i was talking to him like that that's
how i speak to kids
i agree with you i i don't know why we'd
speak to them in a weird different way
keep that up till like six six seven i'm
like
i know i'm like yo and sometimes by the
time they're four or five they got a
better response they actually speak to
you like a but well listen mommy i don't
really well that whatever the guy got
google thinking i'm my blank key you
want that dirty ass [ __ ] blanket yeah
i want my dirty ass [ __ ] blanket [ __ ]
you mean and then you have that
conversation that's great
it's vulgar yes it is
you ever call the little kid a [ __ ]
never ah fun things to do kids are weird
listen stop stop like right now right
now you see i can understand you so
right now you right now you're being a
little [ __ ] right now you swear around
kids um it happened
yeah that's wild
[ __ ] is not swearing i feel like kids
you shouldn't be swearing around kids
[ __ ] is not swearing that's just me
though to what age though
so what age
yeah you know listen i think
i don't know for me i think it's just
generally kids
for as long as possible you try to avoid
being vulgar on them i'm not gonna swear
but i think there's a certain level of
decorum that you have i'm not saying you
got to be weird around the kid and be
like google gaga or anything like that i
mean i feel like swinging around kids
it's just yeah
i can attest to that i can't that's just
me i can agree
i can agree yeah yeah it's a bit [ __ ]
up yeah like i don't know just like
but i don't know i've seen parents swear
at their kids and it just throws me off
every time oh i i remember one time
i saw and that [ __ ] me up because it
was a parent
talking to her kid
and she was
go cleaning your like the the
translation is like go clean your room
[ __ ] and i was like
that's wild
you can't talk to your kids like that
no i said no that's a big no i was like
yeah i do i don't understand yeah but
you know man why you got to be such a
little [ __ ] sometimes you even call
your kid little [ __ ] that's weird
it's not my kids i don't give a [ __ ]
that's weird like i
yo what's good little [ __ ]
and your kids are not black yeah that's
weird
[Laughter]
yeah if you got a white chocolate hey
little [ __ ] to you hey what's really
good though
i hope one day somebody [ __ ] names
their white kid little [ __ ]
makes their official real name pretty
sure there's going to be a white rapper
that's going to come hey my name is
little [ __ ] cause in the hood they call
me a little [ __ ] and you gotta write it
really interestingly so that they get a
bit of leeway like l
i h l
nil
lil
l i h l
n
e.i
ggh
ar
lil nieger
it's
it's scandinavian
that [ __ ] looked like a spelling bee
l-i-h-l-n-e-e-g-r
b
yes
little [ __ ]
can you use can you use that in the
sentence please go to sleep little [ __ ]
okay
may i have the origin please
if scandinavian [ __ ]
it's a kid name okay i got it yes mom